it's that time of the year again no not
the holidays it's time for websites all
across the Internet to count down their
top games of 2015 in keeping with the
spirit Facebook has revealed the 10 most
talked-about games on the social media
site and we're not talking farmville or
mafia wars here there are plenty of
Triple A blockbusters in the mix from
number 10 down to number 1 the top games
are halo 5 guardians star wars
battlefront dying light metal gear solid
5 the phantom pain the witcher 3 wild
hunt batman arkham knight mortal kombat
x call of duty black ops 3 fallout
shelter tied with fallout 4 and fifa 15
additional award touches best mobile
game best web game and game of the year
were also handed out facebook issued a
statement saying what we've learned in
that time is that there is no one golden
approach to choosing the best games some
games have strong retention but don't
grow quickly some games grow
exponentially in a matter of months but
are forgotten within a year older games
have stronger engagement than younger
games newer games launch across mobile
and facebook com simultaneously creating
shifts and player engagement starting
December 17 gamespot will be revealing
its own list of the best games of 2015
counting down from 25 and eventually
crowning the ultimate game of the year
you can find all that and more on our
game of the year hub at gamespot.com /
game of the year I'm Tony Wilson you can
find me on Twitter at chain gun Pope and
for all the best games of the year
you're already in the right place
you